[Music]
we wish you welcome
country that has been internationally
recognized with the highest Improvement
in Europe in terms of law your visit
mother president reconfirms once again
the commitment of European commission
towards Kosovo and our region in this
period
it is very important for us to receive
to continue to receive EU support and
support us in the crisis that we are
facing facing first of all we're energy
crisis which
has affected our region as well we
welcome the fact that the support of the
region is at the center of your visit
and we hope that through close
cooperation we will identify the right
mechanisms to facilitate and to face the
problems related to increase of prices
of energy and to support
projects related to renewable energy
Improvement of energy infrastructure and
network capacity as well as investments
in energy efficient measures
to undertake steps to integrate
Democratic countries of the western
Balkans and the European structures
which is a precondition for peace and
stability in our region this is for the
countries that want to make serious
steps towards new Integrations
we know that if you are completely
committed to integrate our region and we
hopefully think that your visit proves
this is
the support from all the structures of
EU Kosovo despite the fact that it is
the best performer the rule of law and
other indexes in the region and wider
unfortunately
Kosovo is still treated with a different
standard when it comes to visual
liberalization although according to
World Justice project we are the first
in Europe and second in the world when
it comes to reform in the rule of law
which is an additional testimony of our
commitment to strengthen rule of one
democracy in our country citizens of
Kosovo remade isolated in the heart of
Europe a continent to which they belong
and in which they contribute by
protecting democratic values for
citizens of Kosovo it has been a while
but despite meeting all the requirements
and criteria the liberalization has not
come yet I would like to thank you
personally and the European commission
for continuous support
and consistent standpoint since 2018 but
also follow the last confirmation that
Kosovo has met all the Visa
liberalization criteria the reality is
that EU member states did not take a
decision within the council yet so we
hope that called from the European
commission will be respected and
complied with by all members
without a new technical criteria that
would block political decision-making
Republic of Kosovo is very serious in
its euro-atlantic aspirations and it is
very serious in the actions that the
Thunder takes in this regard because of
his 100 percent
approximated
policies and defense policies related to
them
EU integration including sanctions
against Russia a decision that was taken
immediately once EU adopted these
sanctions therefore the progress report
for this year which is the best of
course until now and one of the best in
the region is a testimony of the fact
that this country and its people are
really devoted towards European values
of democracy freedom and rule of law I
would like to use the opportunity to
thank
in relation to Ukraine because this is a
support for the values of freedom for
all of us and as we know the Ukrainian
people is going through challenging and
difficult times as people that has gone
through similar words
the huge importance of having a
supportive allies because of our
experience what we have as people of
Kosovo I assure you that we will
continue to fully support the people of
Ukraine and propose Russia and him yes
evil impact this has been evidenced in
the complete coordination of our
policies with those of our European
allies as you know Madam president the
unprovoked war of Russia has caused
troubles around Europe
this is heard accurately especially in
our continent not only because this
reminds us of a dark past but it also
a concern for us because of the Russians
destabilizing effects and the satellites
but also because it had economic effect
within the Norwegian and continent for
us to be able to overcome all these
challenges
a huge Ally and supporter in Kosovo so
I'm on behalf of Kosovo
citizens we want to thank you
wholeheartedly for never leaving us
alone and we want to thank you for all
your stuff that you will be undertaking
in the future I wish you all the best in
your further visits in the western
buttons
foreign
foreign
fulfilled all the benchmarks and indeed
it was our assessment already in July
but also now we have reaffirmed that you
in July 2018 but we have reaffirmed now
that you have fulfilled all the
necessary criteria and we stand by it
now our task is to convince the whole of
the European Council many members of the
European Council are on your side and it
is very good that these discussions have
restarted
we will work very intensively with the
Czech presidency it needs a lot of
diplomatic effort and explanation and
work back and forth
Can Count On Me personally and count on
us in the commission that we will do
everything to help you on your way
knowing that you're doing this
impressive work
you're doing all this impressive work
against a very uh difficult backdrop and
that is the atrocious war that Russia
has Unleashed against Ukraine it's
sending shock waves through the entire
world
and it is unbelievable how cruel and
brutal the destruction is that Russia
brings onto the Ukrainian people
Russia is terrorizing uh the citizens of
Ukraine deliberately bombing and
targeting
infrastructure civil infrastructure in
the attempt to cut off Ukrainian men
women and children of electricity water
heating with the winter approaching and
we see that Russia is using energy very
strategically as a weapon manipulating
the markets and you feel here in Kosovo
of course also the knock-on effects of
this unbelievable Behavior with the
rising Energy prices the difficulties
and security of supply
um and you have been affected too as you
said but rest assured the European Union
will never give in to this black male
and we are in this together because we
are in one energy Union so we stand side
side by side and our response is unity
and it is solidarity we have to tackle
this crisis we will tackle this crisis
um and we end this together because we
are in one energy Union so for you is
important
you have full access to the Joint
procurement of gas I know that is for
the region important not so important
for Kosovo but you are invited to join
the platform for joint procurement of
gas
you will of course benefit from the
discussions and the legal proposals we
have in the European Union concerning
caps on gas prices at the so-called ttf
level but also the discussions on the
influence that gas prices have on
electricity prices in other words we're
doing everything necessary to tame the
high energy prices and the high
electricity prices and of course as we
are in one energy Union you will benefit
from that too but right now you may need
immediate support
immediate financial budget support so we
will grant 75 million euros for the
immediate support of vulnerable
households or vulnerable businesses and
we will finalize all the necessary
procedures to the end of the year so
that you can get the funding as of
January for your budget
then there is another
piece of investment in Grants these are
500 million euros for the whole regions
where we indeed want to support you on
your path towards energy Independence
and security of supply and this is the
investment in Renewables first and
foremost but also in energy connections
throughout Europe More Energy Efficiency
but as I said the most important for us
is the investment in renewable energy
because renewable energy is not only
good for the climate it's good for the
independence of our region they are
homegrown these renewable energies and
they create good jobs here at home
the support will be channeled under the
economic and investment plan for the
Western Balkan and I know that a lot of
work is already done here in Kosovo you
mentioned it in the Energy Efficiency
measures in the building sector are
important I commend you for the plans of
installation of photovoltaic panels
the upgrade of the district heating with
clean
cities in Kosovo I am very curious to go
to the project that I will visit soon
The Faculty of architecture of Christina
um a very important project that we are
funding and which enables to switch from
have a heavy fuel oil to waste heat
energy
so it's really a double approach get rid
of the waste but in a sustainable way
get out of it
for the district
the environment but also the life of the
inhabitants of Christina Within
my dear president to reconfirm
kosovo's place is in the European Union
I'm deeply convinced of that and you're
showing it on a daily basis
I I will always say Europe is not
complete without Kosovo that's very
clear
and with Russia's War waging against
Ukraine our relations with our Western
Balkan partners partners are more and
more more than ever important and have
to be intensified you said rightly so
it's an investment in peace in stability
and prosperity of our shared continent
so rest assured that the European Union
is committed more than ever to the
enlargement process and we will support
you as good as possible to join us in
the European Union
for that I know a lot of topics are
still to tackle but thank you very much
again for the very good talks we did
have we went in detail into the
different challenges and I'm very
confident by working together that we
will move forward
um and one day you will be a member of
the European Union and I'm waiting for
that as much as you are thank you very
much
welcome
how's it going
foreign
foreign
[Music]
automated
[Music]
[Music]
editor
uh
should I start yes thank you the two
questions addressed to me
so I'm the Visa liberalization as I said
Kosovo has fulfilled all the necessary
benchmarks and we've said that already
in 2018 we repeated it this year a few
weeks ago that also on the technical
update the Visa liberalization you
fulfill all the necessary benchmarks so
this commission stands fully behind you
and we will do everything to convince
the whole of the council in a short
period of time really to address this
topic in a constructive manner what
etias is concerned this is independent
of this process very important for the
European Union
you all know the Ester system for the
United States and it's basically the
same that we require with this technical
instrument from that everybody who
enters the European Union has applied
through that system
independent of the different status of
visa requirements so that there is
transparency on movements and this goes
for everybody and every country around
the European Union and it increases a
lot the trust and the confidence of the
member states of the functioning of the
process
your second question uh was and is on
the license plates
so very briefly but very clear
I think
it's Paramount that rules have to be
followed there are clear rules and laws
and they have to be followed in any
country
and at the same time if there's a
transition period the transition has to
be smooth it has to be inclusive I know
that work is going on on a solution and
I commend all efforts in the context of
the dialogue that is supported by our EU
special representative
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
intelligence
foreign
logo
is
foreign
indeed um you rightly so said that I
praise Kosovo for the progress and yes I
do that uh deliberately because I'm
deeply convinced that you deserve all
the praise for the progress there
the European commission fully recommends
twice by now the Visa liberalization but
as it is in our European union and every
process goes like that the opinion of
the European commission is Paramount to
start a process but then the member
State the 20 members State 27 member
states also have to agree and we have
discussed how we can best team up in
this Czech presidency because that's a
presidency that is supportive in this
Czech presidency how we can best team up
to convince those who are still
skeptical you have quite a number of
member states that are supportive so
that's good too but there's still work
to be done
which I found it
thank you from Clan kosova television uh
my first question is for president
Wonderland today you have come in a very
beautiful day in Christina but in the
next month there is expected a strong
energy crisis you mentioned the
financial support for Kosovo
and knowing that Kosovo is dependent on
the energy import during the winter
but do you have any advice for Kosovo
how can energy policies be aligned with
Kosovo to cope with the crisis more
easily in the short term and in the long
term as well
uh during the story where you will visit
Serbia uh do you have any
recommendations for Belgrade
uh regarding to the dialogue uh and that
um
for the impulsion of uh
the the sanctions against against Russia
uh then you put the theater for
president Osmani uh there is
easy
should I start
so concerning your question on the
energy crisis
um
there are two points I know you are
the energy Supply in Kosovo is built on
domestic coal and on electricity import
because it is not enough so the approach
in the mid and long term would be that
there is strong support to build a
second strong leg mainly also to replace
coal that is with Renewables and the the
investment in the economic and
investment plan the 500 million grants
partially also will support Kosovo in
building this mid and long term solution
in the short term and that's what you
rightly said for the energy crisis the
energy policies Kosovo is completely
embedded in the European Union's
policies so what are we doing
um first of all we are saving energy as
much as possible
the European member states have saved
energy by 15 percent
septembered compared to September last
year it's not always easy it needs a lot
of change in personal Behavior but also
in companies Innovative Behavior how to
save energy but this is Paramount energy
globally is very scarce so we will not
change a lot in the supply of energy
that is globally there therefore it's
important as much as we can save the
better we are in position then we are
procuring together gas gas is often used
to produce electricity and as you are
importing electricity for you the joint
procurement of the European Union is
important
The Joint procurement is there to give
us Market power if we're together as
European Union we are much stronger to
negotiate good prices on the global
market
and then the reforms that we are doing
now right now the legal proposals to
reduce and tame the price not only of
gas but also of electricity this is of
course as important for Kosovo as it is
for all the other European member states
because it should reduce the electricity
prices and bring them to a level that is
more beneficial for the companies I want
to be very clear
that we will go through a difficult
winter but we are much better prepared
now than we were eight months ago we
have despite
the cuts of Russian gas
and 100 billion cubic meter of Russian
gas have been cut we've been able to
replace all that by other suppliers the
United States Norway Algeria Azerbaijan
for example
second we have filled our storages in
the European Union and you benefit from
that effect
by more than 92 percent this is
exceptionally good and as I said we have
regimes of saving
and rules of solidarity in case of
severe disruption and rest assured
Kosovo is always in that European energy
Union so whatever we do we do it
together
yes
foreign
Legion
pictures
foreign
foreign
[Music]